so today I want to ask you about your
opinion on Fifty Shades of Grey
I'm Patrick many of your hoster value
came in weekly and I really needed your
help today so I figure we do a video
about it because you know we're thinking
about painting our wall in our new
office different shades of grey and we
had 50 shades of grey that we were
looking at and I wanted to see what you
thought was the best great for us to
choose so take a look at some of these
colors here which 50 shades of grey were
you thinking about were you thinking
about 50 shades of grey with that movie
coming out in February and you know with
the guy rolling up in an Audi and all
this is that what you were thinking
about your mind went to hold it from
place ah well let me tell you what
today's episode has to do with the
question I posed or what your opinion is
about 50 shades of grey one and it has
nothing to do with it on the other end
it does and here's what it is
you know a lot of times recently people
were asking me st. Patrick how do I get
into more influential markets with
people who you know have a lot of
influence you know how how do you get
into the communities where people wanna
invite you and interview introduce you
to a governor or senator or presidential
candidate or you know extremely
successful business owners who are worth
a few billion dollars or get invited to
have dinner with Prince Edward or some
of these different kinds of how does
that happen because there was a town
nobody wanted to get to know who Patrick
maybe it was but why is that and here's
what I learned this is what I've learned
over time we have different school of
thought there's people that says there's
two things you should never talk about
talk about with your potential people
that you're doing business with right
one is what religion and the other one
is politics and I will tell you the more
I move up with people that I influence
myself would that have a lot of
influence in their lives do you know
what I realize they want to talk about
three things the most they want to talk
about religion they want to talk about
politics and they want to talk about
sports those are typically the three
things that interests them so what does
this have to do with you here today
here's what it has to do when they ask
the question they want to do business
with people who have opinions educated
opinion in these kinds of things they
want to know what you think about it
what are your thoughts about it so a lot
of times
we live this life where people say you
should never read the news or you should
never take a look at what's going on
with current events and all this other
stuff I also don't agree with this
school of thought because when you do
that you're kind of blind in yourself of
what's taking place maybe you I don't
know what's going on in Israel maybe you
want to know what's going on in Iran
maybe you ought to know about the
different kind of negotiation taking
maybe you want to know what happened
with the IRS scandal on the lawsuits
with Tea Party and how they prevent
maybe you ought to find out what
happened with some of these different
scandals that we have with Benghazi
maybe you I don't know some of this
stuff because it has something to do
with you right you ought to know a
little bit about that to have an opinion
about it then on the other side there's
also a lot of these conspiracy videos so
many of it that that also is not
necessary to sit and watch all of these
videos that they can really take your
mind to become negative about life and
the world period I think there needs to
be a balance to be curious about
information but not to the point that it
kind of drags you up from being
successful in life but also not to the
point where you're blinded by everybody
so here's the thing about opinions
there's three different levels about
having opinions on things lowest level
is given uneducated opinion about things
when you do that you lose credibility
with people they no longer want to have
your opinion because it's you know you
the answer you give us doesn't have a
lot of credibility so you lose
credibility with that second one is when
a question is asked for you're in an
environment where a lot of you know top
top-heavy conversations are taking place
you don't have an opinion about it so
you stay quiet and neutral you don't
give anything so you're not necessarily
losing credibility but you're also not
gaining credibility because your answer
was so strong and the last one is given
a I'll answer an educated opinion about
that subject with that person walks away
and they say you know what I really like
that guy don't agree with everything he
said but I like the way he thinks
guess what bring them back to the party
again guess what I want to meet with
them for the second appointment guess
what I want do business with that guy I
don't know what he ought but I want to
business with that guy I'm gonna find
out what he offers I'm gonna find out
what business she's in I want to find
out what she's marketing to me I want to
find out who she's with we gotta invite
her to some of these parties then you
start getting invited to some of these
parties but you yourself you need to
constantly be elevating your thinking to
be growing yourself so not only are you
giving opinions or you give
educated opinions but you're also
getting a lot of value and the next
thing you know is your mind is going to
a whole different level where the the
level of consciousness you're going to
the associations with the people you're
around is that a whole different level
and that opens up a lot of new doors and
new opportunities if you continue doing
that so so that's my message in the week
to you and please be sure to subscribe
to this channel and share your opinion
on the bottom by commenting on this
video
so today I want to know so today I want
to ask you about your opinion enough so
today I want to ask you about your
opinion so today I want to ask you about
your opinion on different no are you
serious that's my message of the week to
you um please be sure to subscribe to
this channel as well as take this
opportunity to share your opinions